yesterday CNN wrote an entire piece
predicting the president would be
shocked that he can't eat steak and
burgers while in India it's so absurd
now is it absurd it's bad for the
country overtime Cena has dozens of
anchors and highly paid expert analysts
and some smart people by the way who
worked there and this is what they
talked about for three years running
what does that tell you it tells you
they can't be trusted with positions of
public trust and in a crisis that
actually matters these people ought to
resign today because it's actually
degrading our public conversation it's
making us dumber and it's blinding us to
what the real threats are it's obvious
to the rest of the world it's not
obvious to us in part because our media
is so stupid and so far up their own
butts that they can't see how the world
is changing author columnist mark Stein
joins us thank you assess the state of
all of this so mark is you gaze around
the globe at the imminent threats
pressing in on us would where would you
rate Russian memes on that list I would
rate them very low along with the threat
that Trump will give Alaska to Putin
he'll give Vermont to Justin Trudeau
long before he does that and that's
win-win for everyone
I would I would slightly disagree with
you
Tucker that this demonstrates the
triviality of CNN in actual fact
something rather profound is going on
here as you know an obsession with
dangerous jokes used to be a sign of
totalitarian societies Milan Kundera
wrote an excellent novel about it called
the joke about a student whose entire
life is ruined
by telling a joke that does that Falls
fails to meet the favor of the Communist
Party and that's actually what's going
on here if you actually listen to what
that all that tripe about memes using
humor to advance problematic ideas and
the Russians must be behind that do you
realize what they say CNN is advancing
the proposition that enjoying a laugh
means you're being met
elated by the Kremlin this is actually
the completely idiotic and it's in its
it's also totally corrosive to the
country I have to ask and this is not
atop the list of important things but I
just can't control myself Joe Biden is
claiming on the campaign trail on at
least three separate occasions that he
was arrested in South Africa during a
party watch this this day thirty years
ago Nelson Mandela walked out of prison
and entered into discussions about
apartheid I had the great honour of
meeting him I had the great honour of
being arrested with our UN Ambassador on
the streets of Soweto trying to get to
seaman Robbins Island I came back from
South Africa trying to see Nelson
Mandela and getting arrested for trying
to see him on Robin's Island he was in
prison is that true well by these own
2007 memoir never mentions being
arrested in South Africa trying to see
Nelson Mandela and someone who's
traveling with him at the time doesn't
remember it either one of Corn Pops
long-lost relatives Mark Steyn is still
with us mark were you there when he was
arrested trying to visit Nelson I I was
there when when when Biden was arrested
trying to see Mahatma Gandhi
apparently Gandhi Mahatma Gandhi didn't
want to swim nude in the pool with Joe
in front of the Secret Service agents so
Joe lent him a loincloth he'd made
himself all these stories are quite
interesting because all these fantasies
of him want to place him at the center
of world events it's like when amy
klobuchar ran into trouble the other
night for forgetting the name of the
Mexican president and Joe Biden
immediately said I'm the only person on
this stage who has met the guy who was
the Mexican president and I met whoever
it was it was the Mexican president
before that and the guy who was the
Mexican president before the guy who was
the Mexican president who was the guy
before the Mexican president he all
it is a slightly perplexing thing that
an irrelevant man wants to place himself
at the center world historical events
and in some subtle way these pitiful
fantasies actually tell you why he's
running for president what's so sad he
was the vice president I mean he went to
the funerals of foreign dictators but
that's it works time I'm so great to see
you as always thanks for kicking off the
week thanks a lot Tucker